Welcome back
to Garys Economics.
Today we are going
to bring you up
to speed
with everything
that has happened
on the economy.
So I've been away
for six months.
I want to do
a video
to basically
bring you up
to date
with everything
that's
been happening
in that time
on the economy.
The first thing
to say
is that
really,
in many ways,
nothing has
changed.
Things
have continued
to progress
basically
in the way
that I expected
that it would,
the way
that I've been
saying
that they will.
And this
is because,
in my opinion,
the economy
continues
to be dominated
by the enormous
amount of money
that was
transferred
from government
to very
rich individuals
during COVID.
Those numbers have
increased slightly,
so I used to speak
a lot about £750
billion
that total
government deficit
since COVID
now is £800
billion in the UK.
So that's £16,000
for every adult
in the country.
That's the total
amount of money
to the rich from
the government.
In the US,
the number is
$10 trillion,
eyewatering
which is $80,000
for every US
taxpayer.
So enormous
amounts of cash
have gone
from the government
to the rich.
In my opinion,
those continue
to drive
the economy
and things
are basically
progressing
as I said
they would.
And we're going
to talk about now
what will happen
from now.
So let's go through
the main points
one at time.
Number
one is inflation.
Inflation
is obviously
the big thing,
which has been
hurting people's
living
standards in
the last few years.
We have
seen inflation fall
significantly
in basically
every country
in the world
in the last year
or so from highs of
in the UK, 10% down
to now, about
4% in the UK
and other countries
already
significantly
lower.
Now this is
what I predicted.
It's basically
what all economists
predicted.
We did a video
maybe about eight
or nine months ago
when Rishi Sunak,
the Prime Minister,
basically
said he would
cut inflation
and at that point
in time
it was already
very obvious
that pretty much
everyone
that inflation
was going to fall.
So this is not a
surprise to anyone.
Now, for me,
this is
pretty much in line
with what
you would expect
if you
see a one off
massive cash gift
from governments
to the richest.
The rich accumulate
a ton of money.
They spend
that money
that pushes
prices up.
But because it was
a one off
cash gift,
we see a one off
increase
in the price level
and then those
prices
start to subside.
Some people
think inflation
will come all
the way down to 2%,
which
is the target.
Some people think
it might struggle
And stick
around these 4%,
3% levels.
Personally,
I think we
probably will see
inflation fall
relatively quickly
and that brings us
to number two,
which is interest
rates.
Now the Central
Bank,
Bank of England
or the Fed,
if you’re
in the US,
move interest rates
to try and manage
inflation.
So since inflation
is falling,
the expectations
for interest
rates
have also fallen.
Now, if you go back
and look at my
predictions earlier
in the year
for interest rates
and house prices,
which you'll
get on to next,
I said interest
rates
will keep rising
and then
as inflation
falls,
will probably start
to see interest
rates flatline.
At this point,
markets
are basically
expecting
that to happen.
So the Bank
of England base
rate is
up to 5.25%. Now,
they didn't
change it
at the
last meeting.
Markets
now expect that
that will basically
be the top.
It will stay at
5.25%, as inflation
falls,
interest rates
will start to fall
again.
There's
a lot of argument
about how far
they will fall.
Markets
think that they'll
probably come down
to eventually
about 4%.
That might take
a couple of years.
Personally,
I think that
inflation will fall
further
and interest rates
will end up
coming down
lower than that.
But that would
depend
based on government
policy,
which will get on
to after we’ve
spoken about
the economics.
The next thing is
house prices.
Now I was very
aggressive
in predicting house
price rises
from the very
beginning of COVID
and we did see
very aggressive
house price rises
at the beginning
of COVID.
Since then,
interest rates
have risen
enormously
from 0%
up to 5.25%.
And I think
a lot of people
have been surprised
that these
aggressive
interest rate
increases
have not led
to aggressive
house
price decreases.
For me,
I think this is
quite
understandable
when you understand
that an enormous
amount of cash
has been
accumulated
by the rich.
Now, when interest
rates
go up a lot,
as they have done.
Many of you
will have seen
mortgage
rates go up.
It becomes
very difficult for,
sort of, middle
class people,
especially poorer
people,
to buy houses
because they rely
on mortgages
and those interest
rates have gone up.
But in the same
time,
the rich have
accumulated
an enormous
amount of money,
which means that
they are able
to buy houses
basically without
using a mortgage,
using a very
small mortgage.
So I think
what we've seen
is two things,
basically.
As interest
rates have gone up,
rich people have
been using their
cash savings,
giving it to their
kids,
giving it
to their grandkids
to buy houses
without mortgages,
which is why house
prices
have not fallen
despite these big
increases
in interest rates.
And the second
thing is that
rich people
are able
now to get high
interest rates
on their savings
accounts.
So they're sort of
sitting on the cash
they've got
getting
high interest
and using it to buy
houses.
This has meant that
we haven't
seen what
a lot of people
have predicted,
which is house
price falls.
Now, I think
house prices is
interesting for me
because I think
probably
what we will see
next is interest
rates will start
to fall
as inflation
starts to fall.
I think once those
interest rates
start to fall,
rich people
will stop
sitting
on these big
piles of cash
in the bank
and they will start
to lend
the money out
at lower rates
for mortgages.
They will start
to buy more houses.
And I'm strongly
expecting
aggressive house
price rises
in the next
couple of years
as the interest
rates fall down.
So I think this
is going to lead to
a while
before that.
I want to talk
about
the very last thing
we've got,
which is living
standards.
So inflation
has fallen
significantly.
I think people are
starting
to realise now
what I was speaking
about earlier
on in the year.
When inflation
falls,
that doesn't
mean prices fall.
So prices
have continued
to rise
throughout
the year.
Prices have
consistently risen
more than wages,
which means
even as inflation
has fallen,
living standards
have continued
to decrease.
The way I see
it really is during
the three years
of COVID,
we paused the
economy and rapidly
increased
inequality.
If you pause
the economy
and rapidly
increase inequality
when you unpause
the economy
is inevitable,
you will see
a significant
fall in
living standards.
I think
that is basically
what we're
seeing now.
The question is
what happens
from here?
Because I think
the way that the
economy is being
presented
in the media at the
moment is largely
that we are
in a recession.
And I think that
kind of gives
the implication
that there is
a temporary period
of decreasing
living standards
and then we will
have a recovery.
I think if you want
to understand
the long term
picture,
it's important
to understand
basically
the sort of second
round effects
of this large
amount of money
that has gone
to the rich.
So up till now,
the rich,
because they'd been
getting higher
levels of interest,
have been
relatively happy
to just sit
on that money
and accumulate
the interest.
Now, as inflation
starts to fall
and interest rates
start to fall,
they will probably
look to invest
that money
more aggressively,
which means
they will start to
essentially
buy houses from
the middle class.
So what
that means is
we will see house
prices go up.
We will see home
ownership rates
from young people
continue to fall.
What we will also
see is
as the rich people
look to use
the money
they've accumulated
and what we already
are seeing,
significant
increases in
rents,
the prices
of luxury
goods, the price
of holidays.
And that is, again,
something
you would expect
when you
see a massive
accumulation
of cash
from the rich.
That basically
means
rents will go up,
house
prices will go up,
and the ability of
owning homes
will become more
out of reach of
ordinary families.
What that means
for young people
from ordinary
and poorer
families is
rent is much more
expensive
when you're young
and you
then have to take
out a much bigger
mortgage
to buy a house,
so you have to pay
much more
in interest.
This increases
the flow of rent
from the poor
to the rich
and increases
the flow
of interest
from the poor
to the rich.
We also have a
massively increased
government debt,
which means that
the government
is now paying debt,
paying interest
to the rich.
You are paying
interest
to the rich much
more on your taxes.
So all of
these second round
effects are
essentially bad.
When you give cash
to the rich,
the rich use
that cash
to buy the assets
from the middle
class,
to buy the debt of
the middle class,
to buy
the government
increased levels
of debt, decreased
levels of home
ownership means
increased
cash flows
from the
middle
class to the rich,
and this will
continue to
rebound through.
So what
that means is
we will continue
to see living
standards fall
in the coming year,
the coming
two years.
I want to talk
a little bit about
how this will
probably play out
politically,
because
we obviously have
an election
coming up next year
in this country.
There's also
an election
in the states.
I think
the most
important thing
you need
to understand
if you want
the future
of the economy,
is that inequality
has greatly
increased.
So it is inevitable
that living
standards have to
fall further.
I think that will
probably dominate
the political
environment
for some time
to come.
I don't think
any mainstream
political parties
at the moment
are serious
about reducing
inequality,
which means that
inequality will
inevitably continue
to increase.
So I think if you
want to understand
politics,
the economic
framework you
need behind
that is to
accept that
from this point,
further
significant falls
in living
standards are
basically certain,
which means you...
what you see
is continued
dissatisfaction
in whichever
political party
is in power,
be that
Conservatives
or Labour
or Democrats
or Republicans.
So I think,
you know,
and I'm
not a professional
political
forecaster,
but I'm
very confident
my economic
forecast,
what you will
probably see
is increased demand
for ordinary
people,
for some sort
of political
alternative.
So it's probably
important
that we understand
what are the likely
political
alternatives.
So I'm
making this video
very shortly
after the Dutch
election in which
for the first time
ever, the Dutch
populist
far right party
essentially won
the election.
Got the highest
number of
seats and
votes. And I think
at the
moment we are in a
situation
where living
standards
will definitely
fall.
They already are
falling, clearly,
and people
will start
to demand
a political
alternative.
And what
that means is,
it becomes
very important
what the most
feasible seeming
political
alternative is.
And when I
look around
at voting trends
in Europe
and in the
US in trends
of political
parties,
it seems to be
pretty clear that
at the moment,
the most popular
sounding
alternative
voice is increased
xenophobia,
anti-immigration
and possibly
increased racism.
And I think that
in the absence of
the creation
of a positive
alternative
narrative,
it's almost certain
that politics
will move this way.
And that is
a direct result
of the fact that
it is
basically certain
the economy will
keep getting worse.
I think
people
are aware when
the economy they're
in is failing,
especially as that
stretches on 10,
20, 30 years.
I think
when you know
that the boat
you're on
is sinking,
you know,
you're going
to basically jump
on the first
lifeboat
that you see.
So I think
what we will see
from this point
further decreases
in living
standards,
which could become
quite fast and
further
demand from
ordinary people
for an alternative
in politics.
And unless
we can create
a positive
alternative
which says
let's distribute
wealth better,
let's increased
living standards,
we're
probably likely to
move towards
these sort of
far right,
anti-immigration,
xenophobic
sentiments
over time.
Of course,
those
political parties,
they will also fail
to improve
the economy
because they will
not deal
with the
fundamental problem
of inequality,
which means that
unless we
create a positive
alternative,
it will probably
simply shift
further
and further
to the right
and in the search
for something
that works. So
that's a relatively
depressing message
to be delivering
at the end
of the year.
But I think
it also makes it
clear
the importance of
what we're doing,
which is,
if we make it
clear to people
what's happening,
which is that
living
standards will
continue to fall,
people will know
that we need
an alternative
and we need to make
it clear
the fundamental
reason for the fall
in living
standards,
which is
the increase
in inequality.
If we decrease
the inequality,
we can improve the
living standards.
If we don't
decrease
the inequality,
living standards
will continue
to decrease
and politics
will continue
to move in more
extreme directions.
But the most
optimistic thing
I can say
is the
massive increase
in inequality mean
that we have
massive opportunity
to enormously
increase
living standards
If we simply
reverse
the increase in
inequality
that we see.
So to conclude,
the economy
continues
to be driven
by inequality.
All the main
economic features
inflation, interest
rates continue to
be driven by that.
Inequality
is increasing
very quickly.
If we don't
decrease that,
living standards
will fall.
If we take action,
we can make things
better.
So support
the channel.
We’re making lots
more videos
in the New Year.
Thank you for
your support.
Good luck.